[Music]  thank you  surprise  [Music]  as soon as you get free  I should have known Osborne wouldn't  have the spine to finish you shut it  down Arc you're gonna hurt a lot more  people this time well that's a risk  we're willing to take  well I'm not  [Music]  hang up  foreign  [Music]  let's say you Scurry out of this  [Music]  now what  foreign  [Music]  we have to shut it down  please tell me how Peter Parker  brilliant but lazy  look at what's happening  we must destroy it  I can't destroy it  [Music]  [Music]  you once spoke to me about intelligence  that it was a gift to be used for the  good of mankind  the privilege  these things have turned you into  something you're not  don't listen to them  it was my dream  sometimes to do what's right we have to  be steady  and give up the thing we want the most  even our dreams  [Music]  you're right  he's right  [Music]  listen  [Music]  listen to me now  listen to me now  now  tell me how to stop it  [Music]  thank you